BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 1: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
IDO GREEN: So hello, and welcome
to another episode of
GDL Israel.
This week, we're going to
actually repeat a session that
we did last week.
Because last week we had some
problems, and then at the end
of the show, the quality
of the video and the
audio wasn't too good.
So we're just going from
scratch today.
And hopefully we'll do an even
a better job because we
already did it once, so we'll
get better and better.
So without further ado, let me
jump into the code and show
you how it's really easy these
days to use and leverage
Google Apps Script in order to
create a powerful backend.
So you don't need to actually
create any service side
coding, and have a nice web
app that could be quite
functional.
And the example that I chose for
this episode is actually a
very simple one-page web app
that I built more than a year
ago to help me manage a
HTML5 training days
event that I ran.
And as you can see here,
let me just share
my screen with you.
Let's make sure that we're
choosing the right--
yes, this is the one.
So hopefully you can see
what I'm showing now.
And this is basically
the github page that
contain all the code.
And you are most welcome
to fork it and browse
it and look at it.
What you can see here is
basically a very simple
one-page site that contain all
the functionality you wish to
have when you're organizing
an event.
And in this specific location,
under the directory of
G-doc-scripts, you can see all
the JavaScript code that
basically will help us
to run the service
side of this website.
The website is something
that you can expect
from an event site.
First, we're talking about the
event and giving a nice link
to register.
Later on, we'll want to open
and share with our users an
update schedule, an
update document.
And that's actually a nice, cool
feature that you can do
with Google Docs.
You just open one document
as a public.
Let everyone write
and read with it.
And because it's a long link,
you can pretty much be safe
that no spammers will get it.
Because if you're doing an event
for 50, 60 people, most
of the cases--
that most of them will
be good citizens.
And the document will
be very productive.
And then we're giving some
information about where the
location of the event is.
And in this case, we give a link
to another document that
we prepared with the map, the
schedule, and even a back
channel so people could
speak with each other.
Last but not least, some
contacts to people that are
speaking at that event.
And then if you're clicking on
"Register," of course you're
getting our Google Doc form
that basically gathered
information from the
participants, and making sure
that we'll be able to track
what they like us to speak
about to aim and to make
sure that we know
the audience in advance.
And then we are gathering some
interesting information that
later on, we could just
have it all in
our spreadsheet here.
Now, the magic here is that in
this spreadsheet, we get a
very nice detailed data
from our participants.
Let's run one of these just to
see how does it look like.
So we go here to
the live form.
And here I'll just
put my details.
Doesn't really matter.
Now the email.
So let's do aaa@example.com.
And company, Google.
And title, developer advocate.
That's my title.
And then, let's say that
we are into Java,
Python, Flash is dead.
So HTML5, and of course maybe
Ruby and JavaScript.
And we're looking both in
internal and external web
apps, and which browser
do you target?
Let's say that we want to target
Chrome and Firefox and
IE9 and above.
So more or less modern
browsers.
And you know what--
I'll add Opera and
Safari, as well.
Give them some love.
And have you heard about
Chrome Frame?
Yes, of course.
And we want to use it when we
can, because it's improved
performance.
And you can see how old it is
because now it's Sencha, we
should probably change it.
The Sencha actually-- we should
leave it, Sencha Touch
maybe right here.
But SproutCore should
be in there.
And we don't have here Angular,
so let's put Other.
And that's it.
Let's submit it.
After we submit it, we're
getting a "thank you." And you
can see here that if
I refresh it--
yeah, probably I'm using--
yeah, it's a different
document, of course.
Because you can see here that
I have the London HTML5
training there.
And here I have my
GDL example.
But nevertheless, let's say we
have the information here.
Later on, if we're opening
the script editor--
and that's done from here,
Script Editor,
it will take a second.
Then basically, all the codes
that I showed you first in the
github is right here.
And here, let's go real
quick on what this
code can do for us.
So first, to the people that
didn't show in the past how
Script Editor in Google
Apps look like.
This is our environment.
It's quite nice that you could
get more or less all the main
functionality that you want,
like saving it, running it,
debugging it.
And in this specific example,
let's try and jump into the
code and go over it when
we are basically
debugging our code.
So let's start with sending
an initial email to our
participant.
This is the function.
And if I do click on the debug,
you can see quite
quickly that basically I have
here a nice window of
debugging the information.
And it stopped on
the first line.
And now, I can do many things.
Of course, I can jump
into the function.
I can go above.
I can do many, many things
that you want.
In this cell location, I'll get
all the information about
different things, like the
variables that I'm watching,
breakpoints that I'm
putting, and so on.
Here what the first we're doing
is just to get a hold of
our active spreadsheet.
Then we have the specific sheet
that we're going to
focus on-- in this case,
it's the registration.
If you noticed, here
we have two
spreadsheets at the bottom.
One is for the registration,
which basically will be filled
up with details.
And the other is with the email
templates that we prepared.
So the nice thing here is that
basically you could use this
same spreadsheet and have
several sheets for the
metadata that you're going to
use, and one for the real data
that you are collecting
for your forms.
In our case, here we're using
the first email that we're
going to confirm the application
of several
participants.
And then when we're filling our
maximum amount of people
that we could host, we could
send a nice other email for
telling them that we don't have
enough space, but we'll
put them in the waiting list.
And if people will
cancel, we'll be
able to put them back.
Then if spots are opened up,
we are able to send a new
email and reassure them that
they are now in the event.
And of course, a reminder a week
or few days before the
event just to make sure that
everyone will bring the right
things and will be at the
right time and place.
And last but not least, to
send a feedback form.
So to ask to gather feedback
after events so we can get
better and better at it.
So in our code, we jumping
back to this form.
And we're collecting basically
a holder to our data sheet.
Then in the data sheet,
it's very useful to
declare a data range.
And in our case, we're starting
in the second row,
because the first one
is for the headers.
And then we're going up to
maximum amount of columns that
we have, which are basically
derived from the amount of
questions that have in the form,
and for the max rows.
All the functions here, the
util functions that we are
using, are down the
road of this file.
So you could browse them
and check them.
Here we are setting some
variables to work with.
And of course, we want to get a
hold of our email templates
so we'll be able to send them.
After we're doing that, there's
a nice function that
we took from the tutorial of
transforming our rows into
JavaScript objects.
And get rows data basically down
this file is a function
that does exactly that.
Then in Objects, we're
getting the objects
we could work with.
Then we're getting--
it's not the nicest thing to
do, but still very useful.
We're going to our active
sheet on the data sheet.
And in 02 in this
location, we're
having some more metadata.
So you can see here that
the max attendees
that we set is 60.
We could give a name to the
event and have some useful
information.
How are we setting it?
Let's just start now that
we have a new menu
that we edit here.
And if we want to set a new
max attendee number, we're
just clicking on the
first menu item.
Let's say that we
have 80 spots.
Clicking OK, and as you can see
here, we just change it.
Let me make it bigger.
It's here.
So after we got this
number, we go here.
And for every row in our data,
we just want to make sure that
we don't have any
response yet.
So for the ones that we want
to respond with yes, we'll
fill this constant, or
no, or waiting list.
And then, we're trying to sum
it up, and just go over the
ones that are responded already
with "yes." For them,
of course, we just want to make
sure they won't get too
many emails.
Actually, more than one,
it's not good for us,
because it's spamming.
So we want just one email
per person per action.
Here we'll just see that our
number of yeses is still lower
than the max amount.
Because if it's bigger than the
max amount, we'll probably
want to send emails to
the waiting list.
But if it's lower than the max--
and that's what it is
right now--
we'll get a template email.
The first one, if you can
remember, A1, which is just
confirming the people that
are OK with the event.
And then, when we have the right
email template here,
we're setting the right place
here to make sure that we're
setting the value of "yes,"
so we won't send this
person a new email.
Then here, we are just going--
getting the right subject to
the email and sending it.
So this is the email text
that we gather.
This is the subject
of the email.
And here, this is where
the magic is done.
We'll just mail apps,
send emails, and
everything is done for us.
You should remember that for
the first time that you run
it, it will put a big warning
sign, are you willing, and
give the permission--
give this script a permission
to run.
And once you do that,
you could run it.
All the emails will get
your Gmail address.
But if you want to prevent your
specific Gmail from being
presented, you could fill here
at the end with more choices,
like no reply, or sending
an alias, and
lots of other things.
Last but not least, we are
updating our objects and
moving forward on that.
You can see here that when we
are updating the waiting list,
basically it's more or
less the same logic.
The only thing that we'll do
here is just to make sure that
we are passing on all the ones
that we marked with waiting
list, and just transforming
them to "yes"
if we have the space.
Now, when we are doing that,
the status here, of course,
will change.
And then we'll be able to
control who is coming to the
event, and who is not coming.
So that's in terms
of the back end.
Other things that we have here,
as you can see here, you
have a nice drop-down that's
showing you all the functions
that we are using.
For instance, if you want to see
how the set max attendance
function looks like.
Just a quick link on
it, and then let's
go here with setMax.
And let's find it again.
And here, you can see
that it marked it
for us in this section.
And basically, what we have here
is a nice way to gather
information from our users with
the browser input box.
And then we just want to make
sure that we are only using
digits in this case.
And it seems that we are
using just digits, so
everything is fine.
And then we are just putting
it in the right spot.
What I suggest to you when
you're doing a real big
complicated application here is
just to make sure that you
use constant here.
It will make your life
much, much easier.
And here is just a simple
warning message when the users
are putting anything that is
different from digits.
If you are wondering how you're
setting the nice, new
menu that we have here, which
we call Hackathon, and you
could give it the name
of the event.
So you could be able to use
it again and again.
This function has done
the magic for you.
We call it onOpen.
So it will know to run it when
your spreadsheet is being
loaded, like in document ready
on a web page, when you are
attaching jQuery, and waiting
for that document ready event.
And in this case, we're
getting the active
spreadsheet, having
some menu items.
And basically, here you can
see this JSON object
containing the two attributes
of name and action.
So this is the menu item
that the user will see.
And when they--
she or he will click
on it, basically
will run this function.
And this function, as you saw
just now in our case, is
opening a nice dialogue
that's gathering
information from our users.
And then, we're just adding
this menu and
giving it a new name.
What you can see here--
it's very, very nice to make
changes, Command-S, it's
saving it immediately.
And now, if we'll refresh this
page, you will see the changes
taking place almost
immediately.
Let's open the script editor.
And now you see that we have GDL
Example menu item, and not
what it used to be.
So everything is quite
responsive in giving you
feedback for what you're
doing quite quickly.
And that's really nice.
And of course, if you are happy
with the results, you
can always publish it and submit
it to the gallery.
So for people that don't know
where the gallery, or how to
approach it--
in every new spreadsheet that
you're opening, you have under
Tools, the script gallery.
And when you're clicking on
it, you have this nice
dialogue that's letting you
see lots of other useful
things that other
developers did.
And basically, I encourage you
to check it out before you are
pulling your sleeves and
starting to code stuff.
Although sometimes it's really
nice to gather things and
build them just in order to
understand them better.
Let's jump a bit to see
our simple code for
the one-page site.
As you so here, I opened
View source.
And you can see quite quickly
that I'm using Modernizr
because it's a great library
and tool that lets us do
feature detection and browser
sniffing, so we know what we
have in each and every item.
And I'm using HTML5
boilerplate.
And I'm getting for free all
these nice hacks that we need
to do if we want to support
other browsers.
And of course, I have
this one metatag.
So if the user is running in
IE and they've got Chrome
Frame, everything will work
faster to them, because it
will know to detect them, and to
actually tell the IE to use
the headless Chrome Frame.
And from there on, it's a very,
very simple site that
we're using, simple navigation
on the top.
And then nothing
too fancy here.
We tried with Bitly just to make
short links that people
could remember, like HTML5
London feedback,
and things like that.
Let me make it even bigger so
it will be easier to read.
So this is what I spoke about.
So everything is quite
easy to understand--
a description of the event.
And then we're heavily
leveraging Google Docs'
sharing capabilities just to
have a back channel to the
people that are participating
in the hackathon.
And just to make sure that we
have a schedule that we are
able to update it on the fly,
so people have one source of
truth during the event.
So here, there is
nothing fancy.
And it's pretty useful just to
have this site up and running,
and doesn't need to worry
about any service side.
Because all the service side, in
terms of information, this
spreadsheet is our database.
And this email template is
giving us the freedom and the
ability to basically give
personal, customized email to
the participants.
As you can see here, we are
using a very simple
methodology to have this dollar
sign, and then this
specific template.
So later on, in our code, and
let's see how we're doing it,
we'll replace first name with
the first name that we have
here in the B column.
How we're doing it, it's
quite straightforward.
You can see here that when
we're sending the email,
basically we're having the
row data email address.
And before that, we have a fill
in template from object.
So this function--
let's just do a quick
Find on it.
Another one, and here it is.
Basically, it's replaced--
it's going into our regular
expression over the template
that we set, and the template
looked like this.
And we have another function
basically that before it, is
just going and checking this
regular expression to know
where or which column we
are talking about.
And after we do that, the
function that I spoke about
just now is the normalizeHeader,
which is
basically taking and just making
sure that we won't work
with any capital letters or
spaces just to make sure that
we have keys to our objects.
And after we're doing that,
we're just replacing the right
template with the names
that we want.
In our case here, when we're
giving the data, the data that
we want to replace will
be the user name.
and the user's first name.
So when we're filling it from
the template, we're having the
right name.
And then we are able to have
this email text field with the
right names.
So that's very straightforward
and easy.
And then the users are getting
nice, customized email with
their first names at the top.
And you can think about lots
of other ways to make those
emails look better and
be more personalized.
By the way, here the emails are
all in text format, but
you could use HTML.
And that's quite nice to be able
to use it, and then have
even richer emails
to the users.
All the information about how to
use it could be found here.
Let's do this real quick.
And this class of MailApp,
giving you all the different
options that you want to do when
you're sending emails.
And for instance here, you are
able to set attachments, and
make sure that it won't be just
text, but HTML, and lots
of other things.
So I think we covered all the
main important parts.
And if we have questions,
this is a good time.
If not, please feel free to
check out this site, which is
ido-green.appspot.com.
Or just use--
let's open the console,
and write it real big.
So it will be @greenido
on Twitter, or
plus.ly/greenido for G+.
So thank you very much.
And until next time, be strong.